today's show is sponsored by vincero
watches which is an american company
building
super premium wrist watches starting at
only about a hundred and fifty dollars
and they're giving you 15 off when you
go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link underneath
this video today's show
also sponsored by blinkist which is the
app that lets you read or listen to
an entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try blinkist totally
free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman that link is underneath the
video as well
i don't know if you guys remember but um
about a year ago
there was a movement that called itself
i guess
classical liberalism which claimed to be
part of some
new center of american politics and in
reality
it was a complete and total ruse
what they wanted to do was to sort of
normalize wacky libertarian conservatism
as if it were the new center of american
politics when it really wasn't the new
center of american politics but
just because that movement was wrong in
identifying a new center
doesn't mean that there isn't an
identifiable new center and that's what
i want to talk about today and i think
the context that will be relevant and
interesting here is that
if we on the left want to keep
moving ourselves to the left as a
country
we want to understand the areas in which
the
average of the country would be
liable to side with us rather than to be
pulled further to the right now i i
don't know if this is necessary but as a
quick disclaimer before we jump into
this
this new center that i'm going to
describe to you these are not
my views i need to i know that if i
don't do this
i will have a hundred messages tomorrow
from people saying david you
centrist shill it is i i know we're not
used to it with donald trump who's
who's unable to do any kind of uh
abstract thinking
but i'm going to describe to you a set
of beliefs that is not mine so these are
not my beliefs i'm to the left
of this new center uh now that being
said let's get into the details gallup
did a very interesting study which
they've done for 20 to 40 years on
different issues
and they looked at where is the country
right now
on a variety of different issues and
they've represented
the issues as well as the shift in
opinion
visually and we're putting that up on
the screen for our visual audience but
i'm also going to describe it to you and
this lets us build up a sort of picture
of where the middle is right now in
america
on a number of issues so let's go
through the eight issues so
on on gun sales the center
the the average of the country right now
the middle
wants more strict gun sales laws than
those that we've had in the past
the center believes that religion is
fairly important but not
very important the center thinks that
military spending is about right
believes the earth should be prioritized
over the economy
and that immigration law should more or
less stay the same in terms of the
number of immigrants coming into the
united states
the center as of today thinks that the
federal income tax is just about right
they don't think it should be raised but
they don't think it should be lowered
that abortion should be legal sometimes
but not always
and that marijuana should be legalized
so remember this
is just an average of the middle but
what's extremely interesting about this
is that it proves that the new center is
not
libertarian it is not classically
liberal
and you really need to look at the
details to understand this new center as
an example
if the new center were merely
libertarian it wouldn't favor stricter
gun laws
for example it wouldn't favor
prioritizing the earth over the economy
because that is code for
we've got to regulate business activity
if the center
were libertarian it wouldn't think
immigration laws were just about right
because true libertarians want total
mobility of labor and that's not what we
currently have
what's also important to understand
about
how we came to this new center is how
opinion on these eight issues has
shifted over time so
again looking at one example in the
early 90s
much of the gun laws should be made more
strict
that changed until 2010 when people
wanted looser and looser gun laws
and then since 2010 we've seen a
reversal
which has very strongly returned to the
early 90s numbers where
the center wants stricter gun laws so
does the left as well
religion has been much more steady in
its change over time the center of
america
has found religion less and less
important over time where it now finds
it
fairly but not very important military
spending
has moved pretty erratically often in
concert with what's going on
militarily at the time and then
interestingly if you look at the trends
on immigration
it is very steady over the last 40 years
that immigration to the united states
uh should should generally speaking be
increased
ending up sort of that it's okay where
it is
and then probably not surprisingly on
marijuana
it's been a steady increase in the
proportion of americans that believe
cannabis should be legalized so
why do we care about this again if we
want to build the left
we must understand where the center is
if we misunderstand where the center is
we are not going to properly structure
our platform
the center is not some small government
pro-business conservative the way we
would
sometimes be be uh convinced
mitt romney is not the center mitt
romney is far more reasonable than
donald trump
mitt romney is far less offensive and
dangerous than donald trump but mitt
romney is not the center and that's
important to understand
when the left thinks the center is
something that it's not
it tries to appeal to the center in the
wrong ways
so let me know what you think i think
that this new center
represents a lot of the changes we've
been following in the united states
which would include
a sort of status quo perspective on some
issues and a progressivization
on other issues let me know what you
think let me know importantly
how you think our understanding of this
new center could be used
to bring more people to us to our side
and to really push
progressive change i am constantly
getting fundraising emails from donald
trump
sometimes i'll get 10 in a day my gmail
has started redirecting them
immediately to spam but i still check
that folder and see them in there
and some of these fundraising emails
from the trump campaign
have seemed more and more panicked more
and more desperate
but it turns out based on multiple new
reports
that donald trump's campaign is having
a financial problem they have had to cut
ads that they are running
they have spent almost 75 percent of all
the money they raised this entire
election cycle and in thinking about
this
you all know that i hate how our
american politics depends on money
and depends on fundraising i think the
system is corrupt i think the system is
corrosive i think it must be changed
it just so happens that this is the
system we have right now
and it just so happens that this could
be a real problem for donald trump
in the last couple of months before the
election according to the new york times
donald trump has largely stopped
advertising on tv
as joe biden is spending more and more
on television particularly in key
states that could be the deciding states
uh with
the more than 360 million dollars that
joe biden raised in august
which is a record and i'll get to that
in a moment the new york times
goes on to say quote the trump campaign
is expected to increase television
spending next week
but several republicans said that bill
stephen trump's campaign manager since
july
was taking a cautious approach after the
former leadership
spent huge sums on television and
digital ads earlier this year
to no discernible effect the light
television spending
and advertising blackouts in some key
states have mystified allies
raising questions about how much cash
the campaign
has in the bank now if you just look at
the top line
you might not be that alarmed for
example you might hear
that trump raised 1.1 billion dollars
and that is true
but that goes back to the start of 2019
and they didn't spend that money on the
primary
uh and that should be an advantage
because joe biden did have to spend
money on the primary but somehow
73 of the 1.1 billion
that has been raised has already been
spent almost identical
to donald trump's business and personal
lives they are spending on stupid things
going back to the new york times quote
the campaign assembled a big and
well-paid staff
and housed the team at a cavernous
well-appointed office in the virginia
suburbs
outsized legal bills were treated as
campaign costs
and more than 100 million dollars was
spent on a television advertising blitz
before the party convention
the point when most of the electorate
historically begins
to play co pay close attention to the
race
so trump having money problems on the
other side of this
joe biden is raising record amounts of
money 365
million dollars raised in august
choosing kamala harris caused
a spike in fundraising and yes
biden has saved a ton of money by
campaigning remotely for a lot of the
pandemic
being able to save up money for the tv
blitz that they are now
doing and you know trump donald trump jr
and others like to laugh at joe biden's
zoom fundraisers those have been major
successes
those zoom fundraisers shockingly
have kept costs down and sometimes bring
in nearly three-quarters of a million
dollars
in 90 minutes so big picture
is this shocking no this is what happens
when
listen we know that trump was using
campaign funds for paying legal bills
we know that trump was using campaign
funds to pay his own family lara trump
pulling a couple hundred grand
uh you know all these different trump
kids and family members getting paid
and i want to remind you that there was
this idea that trump was so wealthy
wealthy that he would self-fund his
campaign he wouldn't even need to
fundraise because he's a
multi-billionaire
in fact not only is he fundraising and
spending all of that money he is now
struggling to fundraise and uh there are
of course
questions about whether money has been
used illegally
the answer is probably yes in reality it
will likely have no repercussions
whatsoever
um the uh last thought on this
i uh i want to go back to this i'm not
telling you this
because i think it's great that we have
a system where the person
i am telling you this because if we're
going to evaluate the campaign
attached to reality we can't ignore
that fundraising is a big signal about
voter enthusiasm and the fact that
donald trump appears to be
so short on cash is not particularly
good for him now later on in the program
we're going to look at polling today
compared to polling on this day four
years ago
and what i told you two to three weeks
ago about how the polling this year
compared to hillary's polling in august
of 2016
that has changed significantly and we're
going to look at that next
remember that this program is available
every day
in its long-form audio format for free
on any of your favorite podcasting
platforms if you're an
itunes gal if you're a spotify bro
if you're a pandora kid whatever
make sure you get the daily long-form
audio podcast
and let me know what you think about the
state of the campaign
in your state by sending me a tweet
i am deep hackman on twitter the david
pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
non-fiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist
blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about
eight bucks a month and you get the
entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
a little bit later i'm going to be doing
a deeper sort of more detailed dive into
yesterday's very very unusual press
briefing that donald trump gave but i
want to focus
in specifically on something for a
moment
where donald trump actually said
something that is completely correct
sort of
but he said it for completely
self-centered and greedy reasons
and unfortunately some on the left have
kind of fallen for it and it's really
disturbing to see so let me kind of set
this all up for you
donald trump sort of nailed and exposed
the military-industrial complex at its
core
during yesterday's press briefing i'm
going to play the clip for you
the only problem is that he seems to
have no awareness of the fact that
he has contributed to growing to feeding
that same military-industrial complex
that he criticized yesterday and of
course the reason that donald trump said
this
was to try to make himself look better
that's always donald trump's
priority so let's go in steps
as we should here is donald trump
explaining why
some of the top people at the pentagon
as he claims
do not like him in reference to the
story
about donald trump allegedly saying
troops who died in combat are losers and
suckers here is donald trump
biden shipped away our jobs threw open
our borders and sent
our youth to fight in these crazy
endless wars and it's one of the reasons
the military i'm not saying the military
is in love with me the soldiers are
the top people in the pentagon probably
aren't because they want to
do nothing but fight wars so that all of
those wonderful companies that make the
bombs and make the planes and make
everything else stay happy
but so this actually
is a critique that makes a lot of sense
donald trump points out that part of how
the pentagon operates
and part of how the military operates is
impossible to extricate it's impossible
to separate from defense
and military contractors i don't
remember a republican president
and even many democratic presidents so
clearly
calling this out good for trump he said
something that
is mostly correct now there's a couple
of problems with this
the main problem of course is that
everything donald trump has done
has actually fed the military-industrial
complex you might think well hey trump's
right he didn't get us into any wars as
he defines them he's not the war
president
but he's certainly done some bombing but
put the bombing aside for a second
donald trump has bragged his entire
presidency about all of the arms deals
and purchases that he has made he's
bragged about how much he sold
to saudi arabia and the deal he brokered
for american military contractors to
saudi arabia
the entire term that he has come up with
of refilling the cupboards
he claims the cupboards were left empty
by barack obama he's talking about
military equipment he regularly brags
about having rebuilt the military bigger
and better
and more powerful than ever before that
is trump feeding the military-industrial
complex that he sounded like he was
criticizing there
so this was sort of like a rare moment
of clarity for trump in some sense but
it's for completely greedy personal
reasons that he stumbled across
something that's sort of true
and he's part of the problem the reason
that donald trump said this
is not to actually critique the
military-industrial complex
in fact everything he's done has
supported it trump was trying to explain
away
why somebody at the military or the
pentagon
might say something negative about him
that is all that he cares about and
very sadly some on the left have fallen
for it
uh i i my instinct is that it's the sort
of tulsi gabbard
crowd they have fallen for this and they
are now saying trump is well to the left
of anybody you know
left of obama left abide no trump isn't
actually calling out the
military-industrial complex trump has
bragged for four years
about feeding and fueling the
military-industrial complex and then my
my last thought on this the
military-industrial complex
isn't even really generals who want to
start wars
and they're mad at trump because they
won't let him he won't let them start a
war
that's not really the way it happens the
way that the military-industrial complex
stuff happens the
revolving door of money is lobbyists
pushing congress for pork and congress
doing it because they want donations and
all of these other projects for their
districts
that's really the military-industrial
complex so yes
trump is right to some degree but the
idea that that's how it works
ignoring the whole lobbying industrial
complex
really misses a big piece of it so okay
you know let's let's praise trump to the
degree that he deserves praise but let's
understand that
he is a huge part of the problem
and is only saying this because he's
trying to explain away the atlantic
story which has of course since been
corroborated
by the associated press and by fox news
and by cnn we actually do i don't
believe that this is
being overly cynical i believe it's
being realistically skeptical tell me if
you think i'm wrong
let's now look at some other outrageous
moments from yesterday's press briefing
so donald trump's press briefings in
general have become completely beyond
parody they often start 15
30 45 60 70 minutes late
never with an explanation completely
disrespectful to members of the press
and to to to the audience quite frankly
um and that's sort of part and parcel of
how we've observed donald trump
behave his entire presidency yesterday
donald trump held
one of these press briefings outside the
white house i guess because it was a
nice day
and he made no sense and he said
outrageously crazy things that should
serve to remind us
every single day every single one of us
that he has to go
he must go it's time let's look at some
of the completely
humiliating and depraved moments donald
trump first of all furious that people
were wearing masks
donald trump demanded that jeff mason
take off his mask
before he would accept a question from
jeff
thank you mr president the issue of what
happens when you were in france
continues to be
you're gonna have to take that off
please just you can take it off your
your health
how many feet are you away i'll speak a
lot well if you don't take it off
you're very muffled so if you would take
it off would be a lot easier
i'll just speak a lot louder is that
better it's better
yeah it's better mr president trump
does not like those masks remember
no one at his huge rally last week in
latrobe pennsylvania
was wearing a mask trump doing another
rally tonight will there be masks
reportedly not later one reporter
did actually pull his mask down or off
before asking a question
trump praised him for not wearing a mask
do you um
you sound so clear as opposed to
everybody else where they refuse
your tweets about the 1619 projects what
a great leader right
really leading by example during a
pandemic uh criticizing those wearing
masks and praising those
not wearing masks and so after we got
past the mask
triggering donald trump again talking
about
all of the crimes that barack obama and
joe biden supposedly committed against
him
usa today my question is about the
durham report which you have talked
about recently
you said let's see what happens now
you've accused people
of committing crimes against you during
the russia investigation
yeah they spied on my campaign that's
right
they spotted my campaign and if they
were democrats they would have been in
jail two years ago
they would have been in jail literally
if this side were
the democrats said they would have been
in jail two years ago for 50-year terms
for treason and other things
my question is do you want the justice
department to indict people over this
i'm not going to say that i have to see
the report i haven't see i purposely
i don't know that was a good thing smart
thing i don't know
but nobody can complain about it i have
every right to have been very much
involved and maybe someday i'll get
involved in it
they spied in my campaign and that
includes biden and obama
now remember that we are still waiting
on exactly
which laws barack obama broke which
crimes did joe biden commit but in the
meantime
trump believes that 50 years in prison
for each of them obama and biden would
be right
this is crazy this is even crazier than
trump saying to hillary during the
debates in 2016
you'd be locked up if i were president
a ton of questions during yesterday's
press briefing
related to of course this blockbuster
story
about donald trump allegedly referring
to troops who died in combat
as losers and suckers trump denied
reports that it was his choice not to
visit a military cemetery in france
is that we had the worst weather i think
it was as bad a rain as i've just about
ever seen
and it was a fog you literally couldn't
see i walked out i didn't have i didn't
need somebody to tell me
i walked out i said there's no way we
can take helicopters in this i
understand helicopters very well
and they said no sir that's been
canceled they would have had to go
secret service i have the whole list
they would have had to go through a very
very busy section
during the day of paris
they would have had to go through the
city yeah
now of course this story already
widely corroborated abundantly cleared
that it tracks with what donald trump
was willing to say publicly
and had been saying publicly for years
including about john mccain
and then again donald trump denies
reports
that he disparaged fallen u.s troops
and uh it's a disgrace who would say a
thing like that only an animal would say
a thing like that
there is nobody that has more respect
for
not only our military but for people
that gave their lives in the military
there's nobody and i think john kelly
knows that i think he would know that i
think he
knows that from me remember trump
publicly said about john mccain he
prefers soldiers who don't get captured
and the topic of john mccain actually
came up
and trump if you can imagine this said
he should be
praised trump demanding credit for not
ruining john mccain's funeral believing
your denials of the atlantic story
because of what you said about john
mccain in the past
do you understand that and have you
asked no i don't
understand have you asked john kelly to
refute that story
no i don't understand it at all now
because i've always been
on the opposite side of john mccain john
mccain like wars
i will be a better warrior than anybody
but when we fight it where we're going
to win them
and frankly i was never a fan of john
mccain you know that that's been very
obvious i was
but i had to approve his entire funeral
i wanted him to get he deserved
a first class you know it all was
approved by me we sent air force one to
pick up the casket a lot of things but
no i was not a fan of john mccain see
guys
none of it can be true because trump
didn't ruin john mccain's fury
funeral and he could have trump could
have ruined john mccain's funeral and he
didn't do it
trump then going on to say that his most
sophisticated friends by the way
who are trump's sophisticated friends
trump's sophisticated friend said to him
he must be the most innocent person ever
to be president be the most
innocent honorable man ever to hold the
office of president think of it
they spent just mueller alone he spent i
guess the real number turned out to be
48 million dollars but whatever it was
many many millions of dollars
they had 18 angry democrats looking
they had fbi agents all over the place
they had every and they have no
collusion friends of mine have said
sophisticated friends have said you've
got to be the most innocent guy
ever to hold this office and there's a
lot of truth to that yeah thank you mr
president
donald trump genuinely seems to believe
that he is completely innocent i
i have gone back back and forth about
this over time
i actually believe trump is so
delusional that he really does think
he's done nothing wrong ever and that
there
is some kind of witch hunt against him i
used to think maybe trump was just
saying it i now believe trump actually
believes it
confirming his total disconnect from
reality
and then donald trump asked about his
postmaster general louis de joy
there are now multiple investigations
into louis de joy
there is speculation that louis de joy
has committed multiple crimes
and donald trump just plays dumb and
says he hasn't really heard too much
about it
mr president if proven true are you okay
with postmaster general
dejoy and the fact that he asked former
employees as private company
to make donations to the gop and then
reimburse them are you okay
i don't know too much about it i read
something this morning but i don't other
than that i have to see it
uh he's very respected man he was
approved very
much by both parties i guess it was sort
of a
an approval that took place by both
parties i don't know exactly what the
story is i'll certainly know within a
short period of time
i just read it for the first time i read
it this morning just like you did
would you support an investigation sir
sure sure
and i think let the investigations go
but
but uh he's a very respected man again
it was a
bipartisan commission postmaster general
is appointed by a bipartisan commission
and we'll see how that goes but no i i
think he's a very honest guy but we'll
see
yeah less yeah trump never seems to have
heard about anything that might be bad
for him
and then lastly donald trump wrapping up
with casual xenophobia as i like to call
it
after not directly answering a single
question
well i want to thank you all and i just
want to wish you a very happy labor day
and we're having tremendous success
whether it's on the vaccines whether
it's on the pandemic the
the plague that came in from china the
china should have never let happen
because i will never feel the same about
china and i just want to again wish you
a happy labor day thank you very much
everybody
so again are these benefiting trump
does trump benefit from doing these
press briefings or is it just doing more
self-inflicted damage i don't know how
many trump has watched this stuff
political observers watch it uh but
they're already mostly decided i don't
think any votes are changing as a result
of that
media outlets cover the highlights
but are these really helping trump in
any way that's what i want to hear from
you about
we'll have more clips and coverage of
this press briefing
and tonight's rally by the way that
donald trump will be doing
um on our instagram page at david pakman
show make sure you're following us there
and make sure you're following me at
david.pacman as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
of our sponsors today is vincero watches
and they're giving you 15 off everything
in the store
if you're a guy looking for the perfect
way to refresh your style
one of the best investments you can make
is in a high quality
wrist watch vincero is an american
company
that has made it possible for everyday
people to afford
a premium watch almost everything they
sell is within the range of about two
hundred dollars but it'll look
like you spent a lot more all of their
watches are made in small batches
from top quality materials and they just
look great
i went on their site and picked out a
watch from their icon automatic
collection the one i got is in
mesh matte black and i love it it's
simple sleek elegant
goes great with just about anything i'm
wearing and i've gotten a ton of
compliments on it
you'll get 15 off everything in their
store when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show
today we're going to continue our
conversation about
monopoly and corporate power with david
dayan who's the executive editor
at the american prospect and also author
of the new book
monopolize life in the age of corporate
power it's great to have you on david
yeah great to be here thanks so we
recently spoke to tom hartman
a little bit who's also written about um
monopoly
and uh he looked very very closely at
some of the history
of monopoly power in the united states
maybe
we could start with you with a sort of
where we are today
what what are the industries and areas
where monopoly power
seems to be sort of the prevailing force
industries or
or other areas of american life
i think it would be easier to tell you
what industries aren't
okay because it's uh it's a very
pervasive situation
basically look across the landscape of
america and and
all of these sectors of the economy and
you find
more concentration and more
consolidation and that stands to reason
because
40 years ago we kind of stopped
enforcing
uh antitrust law and and anti-monopoly
law
and and this is the result so you have
you know
four banks that control about 60 percent
of all deposits
for airlines that control eighty percent
of domestic routes
you have concentration in hospital
networks where
locally uh uh in metropolitan areas
about
ninety percent of those are highly
concentrated
uh you have obviously pharmaceutical
monopolies the monopoly is granted by
the government
uh you have facebook and google and
amazon
all predominant in their various parts
of the internet search and social media
and e-commerce so
uh it's hard really to find uh an area
that isn't
tightly concentrated at this stage is
there
a fixed uh sort of uh number that you
look at in terms of x number of firms
can
control y percent of the market or does
it really depend on the industry we're
talking about
i mean technically speaking there is
there's this thing called the herfindahl
hirschmann index
which you don't have to know about
anymore but um it basically means
uh it sets a number uh above which
a certain level uh you know a market is
highly concentrated
how you define a market sometimes comes
into play with these and and
uh at the at the level of enforcement
uh sometimes that that line is drawn
very tightly
uh to say well if you're talking about
local
search in this local area then maybe
that's not
tightly concentrated but if you look
sort of with your eyes in reality then
yes obviously a market is concentrated
um you know there used to be much uh
more uh precise standards around this
that
there were market share thresholds where
uh
if if the justice department saw that a
company
owned more or controlled more than 30
percent of a market or
35 or some number uh that they would
step in
and move to break up that that that
industry or or or deny a merger for
those reasons
we don't have that as much today this
performed all hirschmann is very
technical
uh as i say you can draw the line in
various different ways and so
um you know i prefer to look at this
sort of in
on an experiential basis if you go out
in the world
and uh you know you go into your
supermarket aisle and you see the same
uh it looks like a lot of uh different
choices but a lot of them are made by
the same companies
uh if you you know try to rent a car go
on a flight or
you know do the things that you do
throughout your day you
find that there's more and more
concentration within
uh those sectors and those service
providers
i think a lot of people if asked what's
the concern
about monopoly power overwhelmingly
people would say well uh if few firms
control a market they can drive up the
price that i pay
for a good or a service but it goes well
beyond that doesn't it
yes it does uh i mean it doesn't go
beyond that in terms of how the justice
department and the federal trade
commission look at things that they have
now this sort of
consumer welfare standard and that has
really been devolved into price
where if if prices are expected to go
down
they approved the merger uh but there's
so much more that goes into it you're
talking about quality
uh you know there's no incentive to to
make a service better
if uh there's only one option that a
person has
uh when you're talking about disruption
of supply chains and disruption of
service
uh that magnifies when there are only a
few providers
uh you look at airlines that
glitch often their computer systems and
they shut down thousands of flights in a
cascading fashion that wouldn't be as
much of a problem
if there were many service providers
many airline carriers
uh that were uh you know doing flights
all around the nation
uh you look at inequality and
uh uh particularly regional inequality
if uh the large firms on the coast are
sort of
extracting all the wealth from uh
areas uh that are uh you know said to be
left behind
then uh that creates a regional
imbalance which has
implications not just for the economy
but for our politics
uh if you uh think about innovation
uh the if you have large firms that
don't want competitors
they essentially sit on innovation and
find innovators and
either copy their their uh efforts or or
squash their efforts or just buy them
out and then
and put them away uh in the book i talk
about a
number of these uh uh possibilities and
and
and and circumstances uh where
price is not the main driver of what the
harm is
uh from monopoly and so i i think
there's a tremendous amount
of implications to a more concentrated
system
i want to try to draw a little bit of a
distinction
maybe between some industries and others
and kind of see where you come out on
this
in thinking about airlines for example
airlines are a little different than
some other industries
in that the capital required because
you're talking about
outrageously expensive airplanes uh
the the capital required is much higher
than in certain other industries like
for example to open a local bookstore
which might eventually be driven out of
business by amazon
can you talk a little bit about what
type of changes or solutions you would
like to see
within the airline industry because it
seems very tough
to um do anything other than
break up airlines once they get too big
because the barriers to entry to begin
with are just so high
i mean what you're talking about there
uh and and you see this
in utilities for example so it doesn't
cost it's not cost effective to run
seven different wires to a particular
residence and have that person pick and
choose between the best service
right that's just that just would be
completely cost
prohibitive so what do we do with
utilities we heavily regulate them
so that they have a natural monopoly
but uh we we put them in a situation
where they're not
gouging customers where they're not uh
providing
substandard service uh and things like
that
and so you can sort of extend that out
the
regulated public utility model and it
actually uh
historically is how we handled airlines
in the 1930s
we had a a a regulating uh board called
the civil aeronautics board
that said okay you can uh you can have a
certain amount of profit for a certain
uh uh level of capacity on your airline
but you also have to serve the entire
country you have to
make sure that if you live in topeka
kansas
or if you live in uh portland maine
you have access to airlines uh
and and and and flights and travel uh
that allows us to connect the entire
country together
what we did in the 1970s we deregulated
the airlines
uh this led at first to an explosion of
competition actually
but then it all uh it was it was it was
not a virtuous competition everyone was
lowering and lowering prices and then
they
completely cost ineffective and then you
had this these
giant amount of mergers and now what we
have with the hub and scope
spoke model is that certain cities have
been just completely left behind
they there just is no airline service to
large sections of the country and
certainly not direct flights
uh and as cities like cincinnati and
and and others have have seen their
their international airports sort of
wither and then seen
businesses who who rely on business
travel
leave those areas and and move to
larger parts of the country so this this
sort of with the flick of a wrist and
and the change of a
where a hub is you can turn a city from
a a world-class city into a second-class
city
and what the civil aeronautics board did
was
it was trying to prevent that it was
trying to sort of
level the playing field and so what i
think needs to be done
is that when you have businesses like
airlines or utilities
you regulate them in such a way that
provides the most service to the most
people
with with the least disruption and uh so
airlines actually a very good model for
this concept
of a regulated public utility can you
talk a little bit about
which uh industry monopolies
have been exposed through coronavirus
specifically are there are there certain
specific areas we should be looking
where
the the virus and the pandemic have sort
of shined a light on hey
this industry that industry is very much
under monopoly control
well i think what's happened is it's
accelerated
uh uh trends that we've seen for the
last 40 years
for combination of factors number one
it's simply the case that small
businesses do not have the kind of cash
reserve that large businesses do and
we've seen
thousands tens of thousands of small
businesses go under
thereby giving more market share to the
large incumbents
the second reason is the cares act uh
which
provided a massive amounts of support
for
large businesses particularly those uh
were public
publicly traded companies uh by propping
up asset prices
whereas small businesses got this ppp
which is an eight-week
uh fund for uh funding uh payrolls
uh obviously we're in the six months
month of this pandemic so eight weeks
was
definitely not enough and this imbalance
has led to more and more
uh market share going towards the top
and then the third thing
is uh the the changes in sort of
are our patterns of life uh working from
home
uh doing deliveries that has benefited
the large incumbents like amazon
like uh uh certainly the the
technological uh uh things like
skype what we're using now which is a
division of microsoft
or google tools or things that people
are using to make the work from home
process
work uh so you know i think
i think what i would say is it's
accelerated this trend
uh and now we're at a position where
five major tech stocks
are roughly one-quarter of the value of
the entire s p
500 which has never been seen before in
history so we're
we're getting into this position with
fewer and fewer
uh companies controlling more and more
of the economy and it's very dangerous
for all the reasons that we've outlined
in the sort of limited time we have left
what do you think is responsible for
getting the us
away from uh breaking up monopolies and
and actually it's not even about uh
creating law really just enforcing the
laws that
that are there and were enforced more
strictly for for a time is it as simple
as regular
regulatory capture and um the
connections
between the political system and these
corporations or is it more more complex
than that
you can really boil it down to one man
and that man is named robert bork
uh he was the uh former reagan nominee
for the supreme court he was a failed
uh uh nominee uh for the supreme court
but he had much more
impact uh outside of of the federal
bench
uh he wrote the book the antitrust
paradox in 1978 which sort of brought us
this consumer welfare uh uh
prism through which to to view mergers
uh his idea was as long
as a merger makes uh the merged company
more efficient
then we should allow the merger and his
corollary was
that any merger makes a company more
efficient so it was perfectly
tautological reasoning
that that essentially made it impossible
to stop a merger
and it was internalized by both the
anti-trust authorities the justice
department changed its guidelines in
1982 based on borkian principles
and also the federal judiciary which
internalized these concepts
as well so uh thanks to bork and and
and the ideas that he brought forward
with the law and economics
movement which uh you know was largely
uh out of the university of chicago
uh we we have you know changed and
reinterpreted
all of these century-old anti-trust laws
without really
changing a word uh what is what is
changing now
is we're starting to get an awareness of
that uh and there's sort of a nascent
movement
of thinkers and journalists and and and
uh academics
who are pushing back finally on on this
sort of borkian concept
of antitrust and uh we're starting to
see this bubble up into the political
system
uh you know in july we had the house
antitrust subcommittee
have the the ceos of all the major tech
companies in for a hearing
which was very aggressive as to their
anti-competitive harms uh that they were
placing on on businesses and uh partners
that work with them
as well as the public uh so i think the
way
that we're going to counteract this is
through a political movement
uh that's really the only way that the
antitrust laws got put in place in the
first place
and it's the only way that we're going
to get a a re-reinterpretation of them
if you will
uh to restore the concepts
that were brought forward uh initially
with these laws which was to
protect and preserve competition well uh
well said we've been speaking with david
dayan who's the executive director at
the american prospect
the book is monopolized life in the age
of corporate power
david really appreciate your time well
thanks thanks for having me thanks for
your interest
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way is through
membership which includes the world
famous bonus show as well as commercial
free audio and video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
earlier in the show i gave you the
details of this cash crunch that's
hitting the donald trump campaign where
they've already spent
uh more than 70 percent of all the money
they've raised dating
dating back to early 2019 and are having
a pretty serious financial problems we
also already looked at donald trump
yesterday during one of these
deranged press briefings making very
little sense seeming furious about
journalists wearing masks and just
insulting people calling joe biden
stupid
trump also absolutely lost it on twitter
yesterday tweeting and retweeting
70 times in one day now as i've said
before
most normal people with regular 40 hour
a week jobs
are too busy to tweet 70 times a day i
make it a point to try to connect with
people on twitter and to at least do a
little bit of tweeting and you know i'm
not
that busy i'm certainly not the
president of the united states
and i'm rarely tweeting more than three
or four times a day and donald trump
with 70
70 tweets and retweets yesterday
take a look at some of the outrageous
things that he tweeted because the
themes are important here
and there's actually a great website
trumptwitterarchive.com
it lets you look at tweets much more at
a glance and look at tweet
trends and themes that we see now
earlier in the morning
donald trump retweeted a whole bunch of
stuff about uh black
violence and police being good
retweeting a bunch of things from the
always action account
for example uh black man exposes black
lives matter
police officer saves baby's life
um the reason why president donald trump
was elected and the reason why he will
be elected again with a link to an
outrageous propaganda video so there
were a bunch of those
types of tweets earlier on in the day
then trump started insulting people for
example
quote biden underperforming what else is
new
the story of his life attacking john
bolton his former national security
adviser saying
just heard that wacko john bolton
was talking of the fact that i discussed
love letters from kim jong-un
as though i viewed them as just that
obviously
was just being sarcastic bolton was such
a jerk
then around midday remember this is just
it's all day
around midday trump retweeting about 10
tweets from an account called
tvnews hq uh
all propaganda videos fox news videos
being retweeted
uh tweets about the dow which by the way
has not been doing so well stock market
has not been doing well
recently conspiracy theories and all
sorts of agit
trash as i like to call it and then of
course donald trump getting into the
phase of the day where he just lies
about coronavirus
tweeting quote starting to get very high
marks
in our handling of the coronavirus china
virus
especially when compared to other
countries and areas of the world
now the vaccines plus are coming and
fast
and we're going to talk on the friday
show much more
in depth about what kind of impact could
we see
from the vaccine announcement that we're
expecting
in october from trump not the vaccine
distribution
but the vaccine announcement and of
course donald trump insisting that he's
just done so well on coronavirus
i i i guess there's probably some people
who do believe it there are trump
sycophants who will believe anything
but you know more than 193 000 deaths
when trump said we would have 60 000
deaths maybe by the time it was all said
and done
trump said 15 cases would soon be zero
now with 193
almost 194 000 deaths as of this moment
donald trump insisting that he's just
done really really great
on coronavirus and again going all day
the tweets started at 7am eastern
yesterday
they ended around 9pm all day unless you
uh with the exception of when trump was
doing the press briefing yesterday
afternoon
he's tweeting every hour it it is just
tweets
after tweets after tweet this is not
normal
this is not needed this is not helping
this is
worsening our relationships with our
historical allies
this is very much something other than
actually dealing with the pressing
issues that we're facing today
it does nothing for you the american
people and i know some people write off
the tweets as
not important donald trump has chosen to
communicate
his perspective and his positions to the
world essentially
uh through twitter and if he is chosen
choosing to use this tool
then certainly we should be using it to
see where trump's head is
and it is not in a good place at all and
it is being reflected in the polls and
that's what i want to talk about next
i came to you very carefully about two
weeks ago
and i told you if you compare the polls
today now this was like august 20th
i said to you on august 20th if you
compare the polls today
to the polls four years ago between joe
biden i'm sorry between hillary clinton
and donald
trump there was only a 0.7 point
difference
over that four-year period and what i
said on august 20th was
i wouldn't be super confident with a
polling difference
of 0.7 points when we compare
2016 to 2020. we now have another two
weeks of polling data
and we now have a different situation
joe biden today is in a different
position
than that in which hillary clinton found
herself four years ago today so let's
look at the numbers
then we'll talk about the significance
then we'll look at states
right now on average according to real
clear politics
joe biden is leading donald trump
nationally
by 7.1 now this is an average
there are recent polls where biden is
only up by two the latest emerson poll
is one example
there are polls where biden is up by 10
like the recent cbs yougov poll
the latest usc poll but on average
biden is up 7.1 okay
on this day in 2016 meaning
september 8 2016 hillary clinton was
leading donald trump by only 2.8 percent
this is now a different situation if you
go back
four years hillary clinton's lead was
significantly smaller than that of joe
biden today now what does this mean
nothing nothing nothing everyone must
vote it is simply
interesting to consider that as of today
joe biden's lead is 2.5 times that of
hillary clinton
exactly four years ago what are the odds
that if trump loses by seven he wins the
electoral college
they are low but unless we vote
it means nothing and of course this is
an electoral race which will come
down to a handful of states and looking
at recent polling some
highlights from the last five days
donald trump is winning by five in
missouri as of yesterday now why do we
care about missouri
we care about missouri because in 2016
trump won missouri by 19.
if donald trump were to win missouri by
only five that's not good for him
in wisconsin biden is up eight in a
right-leaning rasmussen poll and up six
in wisconsin
in a cbs news yougov poll uh that was
almost tied in 2016. texas
has trump at only plus two according to
the dallas morning news remember that in
2016
trump won texas by nine if trump were to
win texas by only two
that would be a very interesting signal
about the south
joe biden is currently up 15 in new
mexico
that would be a wild win in 2016 hillary
did win new mexico but only by
eight of course if joe biden doubles his
margin
of victory in new mexico that would be
huge one note is
in 2016 libertarian gary johnson had
nine
in new mexico uh we'll talk about the
the lack of gary johnson
in a moment we have a recent florida
poll from the republican trafalgar group
which has trump plus three in florida
florida could be a fight but we've also
got a quinnipiac poll from florida that
has biden plus three
remember florida is likely much more
important
in the path to 270 electoral votes for
donald trump
than it is for joe biden now let me go
back to what i just mentioned
not only do we not have gary johnson
this year we also don't have jill stein
and if you go back and look at the
numbers from 2016 gary johnson ended up
with a little over
three percent of the vote in 2016
nationally jill stein ended up with
about one percent of the vote
jill stein's vote alone could
could have flipped some states from
hillary to trump and could be solely
responsible for hillary clinton losing
and donald trump winning
electorally but with gary johnson
uh not pulling 3.2 percent of the vote
we also have to consider the impact of
that
and so anybody saying the third party
difference this year is going to make it
very clear that trump will win or trump
will lose
i think we don't know that i think
everybody has to vote i think we've got
to count every ballot
now last word of warning and this is
this is maybe the most important thing
the polls as accurate as they might be
about the intentions of voters cannot
tell us
the effect of voter suppression the
polls don't tell us the effect of
messing with the postal service
the polls cannot account for voter
purges
that we know are going on and have been
reporting on and so this is the really
important message
biden today with a lead that's two and a
half times larger than hillary's lead in
2016 that's a beautiful thing
that's a great thing but it does not
account for any of the foul play and if
it's close
and especially if trump comes out ahead
on election night in some states
and then the lead starts to shrink as
absentee ballots are counted in the days
following and it goes more and more to
joe biden
donald trump will use courts many of
which are overseen by the judges
he installed to try to stop the counting
of absentee ballots
so is 2.5 x in terms of
the lead uh the the the multiple by
which joe biden is leading
uh over hillary clinton's lead good for
us well yeah it's good
but given all of these other question
marks i would be far more comfortable if
the lead were bigger
and i would be far more comfortable if i
knew we were going to absolutely crush
turnout so the message is
we've got to vote we've got to vote i
got a call
from a brand new dad this morning
take a listen to this voicemail left to
me
at 219 to david p
hey david um long time listener first
time caller here from a live heart to
seattle
yes listen uh my daughter my first
daughter was born um
about 20 minutes ago and one of my first
thoughts is
wow oh my gosh i just brought a child
into this world
during this election and during
everything that's going on
um i'd just love for you to give a shout
out on your show to my daughter nikoia
and uh
just reassuring me that i'm gonna be
able to raise my daughter in this world
all right thank you you do a great job
and i really appreciate your work well
listen congratulations welcome to the
world
to nicoya um i think we have to be
realistic here you we
we don't have contro much like i said to
the caller yesterday the philosophy of
stoicism comes to mind
clearly what matters is whether this new
dad
does everything he can
to improve the world for his daughter
ultimately it is not up to him a planet
of seven eight billion people
is not one that can be controlled by
just
one person but the fact that you're
thinking in
these terms tells me that you're going
to do a great job
and we all have to work together in
order to
create the best possible situation not
just for our kids but their kids and
their kids and their kids and we do have
a monumental
event that could alter the course of
history coming up just a few weeks from
now
on the bonus show today a saudi court
has sentenced
suspects in the jamal khashoggi murder
we will talk about a uh coronavirus
guideline
avoiding barr which secretly had 300
people inside of it and we will also
talk about the continuation of julian
assange's extradition hearing
this story is still going on and it's
unlikely to go away anytime soon all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show
remember this program is mostly funded
by members
i am asking you for your support if you
like what we do
or even if you hate it but think it's
important
grab yourself a membership at
jointpakman.com
and you'll be able to join us on the
bonus show as well
thanks so much for watching today's
episode just a reminder today's program
was made possible by vincero
watches the american watchmaker building
super quality wrist watches
but making them affordable for everyday
people and they're giving you 15
off when you go to davidpakman.com
vincero
today's show also sponsored by blinkist
blinkist is the app that lets you read
or listen to an entire nonfiction book
in 15 minutes and you can try blinkist
for free and get 25 off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put that link down
below
underneath the video